[Music]
this is a good story or situation
because
anybody who's ever worked like a regular
job uh which i have i worked many
regular jobs yeah and you remember when
you were closing when it was like
closing time and then somebody starts
knocking even though like you just
locked the door yeah yeah that's the
worst i don't know i liked
working so i'm a i'm a nut job i think
everybody should do a service and like
job like sort of
yeah
um yeah for sure especially serving
people absolutely i don't think these
two
uh understood it that way this is a
couple that arrived at coldstone
at 8 29
so uh and they close at 8 30. the ice
cream is already packed
right thank you the stuff is already
packed away
right right there's a lot that goes into
closing for ice cream all the candies
that are out you can't just restart an
ice cream place let me get into their
head a little bit
it's right there
they look [ __ ] scoopy here's uh
here's the situation
for uh
yeah
this is being recorded from uh the
perspective of the people behind the
original like they think they're right
or something oh yeah oh my god no
they're right they're right i think it's
gonna be fine though
we told you
there's a sign on the door that says
exactly what time we open exactly
[Laughter]
because if we let you in we let
everybody in we like you and i ate the
dog my daughter was four years
[Laughter]
so at this point he wants to fight the
kids
[Music]
excuse me
[Laughter]
of jobs
[Laughter]
is such a great line
it's one minute they need to be served
okay that's what we need to know what's
your take my take is if you yell at them
a little bit louder they'll just they
didn't yell hard enough right but can
you imagine if you gave in
and how do you serve someone ice cream
and they're that pissed you're like all
right which one do you want rocky road
man
i mean like you're not gonna get what
you want like you attract more bees with
money like
you think yeah like screaming i just
can't imagine still serving them with
everyone's mood being that like
so tense yeah just trying to
what would you like single or double
mint chocolate chip like at that point
there's no way it's going back or
it's like hey uh yeah which one do you
want okay i'll just go make it in the
back
see that's what i'm afraid of it's your
pizza yeah
cook it up
stir it up
and then that one might be so chilly
it's cold it's a bad idea
you just never know what they're gonna
do to your food yeah why would you do
that no but they brought their daughter
from michigan who's four
my daughter is four and she needs her
ice cream so give her her ice cream and
my whole thing is why close at 8 30.
they should be closing at 9 o'clock they
should round up you know what i mean
like 8 30 is a weird yeah 30's are weird
30's 30's are a little weird 30's right
a little bit i'll agree with you on that
let's let's fact check this yeah
i got you to agree they need to like
whole number it yeah whole number it
dude what is this
ridiculous
i'll never do that if i'm opening up a
shop it'll never be on the you are
opening up a shop i am and i don't
believe in the 30 what time you guys
going to close good whenever the plaza
allows me to what if the plaza is at 9
30 i'm like guys i think we're gonna
have to close at 9 30.
i need that 30 minutes open and close at
a very specific time like like 8 23 and
then like close or even harder 8.62 yeah
like what what the hell hold on nine i
didn't know i was gonna have to do math
i just want to come get some [ __ ]
chai key you're like oh that's 9 30.
that's 9 32. yeah
i don't understand why they don't do
military time here
it's more easier to understand you know
yeah you like military time better i
always get confused yeah you subtract oh
is it 12 20 just subtract two it's
easier
is 24 is it's 8 30 20 30
minus 12 right
i don't know what you said bro 14
o'clock just minus two that's noon oh
not really it's that's two
so you think i just don't understand
like why it had to get to that point
like if you walk in they're like hey
we're close okay i'm gonna go find an
ice cream store that is open like
there's an easy solution is always open
but have you ever been hangry before
because sure
does it does it
grant that kind of reaction yeah i think
so because it's like the incredible hulk
right it's like the incredible hunger i
think it like turns people into just
straight up no you don't have your um
you know you don't think anymore you're
just hungry you're not hungry for ice
cream though bro behind all that anger
he's actually having he's actually
having a great time because he's
probably like so like excited by the
anger that he's like let me just go into
it he's like already invested in being
that way he just wants to be righteous
it's more about being right than the ice
cream and i think it was also his cheat
day too so i think
i think that was factoring that's true
because he looked pretty small so he's
like you know what i've been waiting all
month for this
years even
and today was my cheat day and you guys
close on a 30 so this is the worst day
of my [ __ ] life
i just can't imagine a world where like
um at an ice cream place you'll get the
desired result acting like that ice
cream gets people mad though have you
have you seen that video where they went
up to the drive the mcdonald drive-thru
right and then they ran out of soft
serve and a guy got so mad he climbed
into the window and started beating up
people do you want to do that what i
would do there's no soft siding come
back out with
two cones of software why do that what i
do is i pull the mcdonald's and pulley
through the window into my vehicle oh
yeah yeah
yeah yeah take them around the block
that's more sensible yeah do you think i
think it's sugar big sugar it's big
sugar it's a big [ __ ] big sugar big
sugar
egg sugar so big big sugars out there
[ __ ]
making people addicted addicted to the
sugar huh i'm talking about suge knight
[ __ ]
it's his fault
it's his fault don't mention his name
bro
yeah beat up and [ __ ] sorry about that
getting hit by a car with him driving
you know yeah so if
anybody who's um you know in the
comments tell us where you work and tell
us if you would do that for someone who
came in at 8 29 yelling like crazy
that's great it doesn't seem like that
would ever happen anywhere where they
would go oh sorry okay fine you're not
gonna get the outcome no not at all you
know where you would though okay so
here's my rule of thumb if it's like
let's say it's a store close at nine
right if it's like a american chain or
whatever i'm like i'm not gonna go in 30
minutes before if it's a chinese
restaurant you can go there at nine and
then they'll be like okay come on come
on come on sit down
but then they'll start stacking up
chairs and tables around everywhere
around you but they'll let you eat
and then while you're eating the chefs
and the cooks everyone will come out and
they'll [ __ ] everyone's eating and
then they'll just be like can you just
take care of this check or five that's
true and then and then while they're
closing up the restaurant they'll ask
you to leave that's also because they're
they're usually non-corporate oh yeah so
there's no people have to clock out at a
certain time too like right there's
other variables that they're like
like jamba juice would never be able to
do that like depending on what the
corporation is also you know what uh
there is an exception to this there is a
place that even at a minute or even
seconds before closing they will let you
do the thing
disneyland
if you can get to the line of the right
of your choice a minute before closing
they have to let you go through and
finish the ride they will gladly do it
yeah you can go to like so right a
minute before closing if you get to the
space mountain line they'll just go okay
cool and then right after you when the
clock ticks
put the chain back down really great so
the person behind you you could be there
an extra like 30 45 minutes and they'll
still just like clear they'll clear
everybody like everyone will get their
ride and then it's closed and i think
basically go the last 30 40 minutes
yeah hit all your rides right and call
it a night i think that's so freaking
cool because this guy was making the
claim that he was waiting in line and
they
were saying like oh you didn't let us
come in or whatever yeah i think cameras
yeah but also it's like were you though
but then why was he outside waiting in
line at 8 29 maybe he wasn't maybe he
was just lying because they said oh no
you were here at 8 30. like we saw you
yeah all right summoner
yeah you don't think i don't think he
was lying seems like a man of honor but
he pulled his phone out so
he was filming the best too that's the
best to all this [ __ ] oh i'm filming you
i'm filming you back with you right now
you found me i'm filming you i'm [ __ ]
put this [ __ ] on the internet right it
is 24 hours you know what though there's
no one ever there to scoop the ice cream
for you that's true it's just there and
then you're just like i you know what i
really want though is their scooper that
gun and it comes out cylindrical oh i
love that thing i love that thing the
cylindrical thing can i tell you guys a
write aid story yeah he's kind of better
did anyone die a little bit better okay
yeah my passion for it
i'll tell you
so i used to have this like fun thing
that i would do every time i was with
friends we would go to rite aid we would
buy ice cream and we would take a cool
picture right before the ice cream thing
was like my thing i would do i would
just tag rite aid or hashtag write it
they lost a good influencer and i did
all the time eventually someone from
their marketing reached out and said we
love that you always do that we think
it's really cool um and i was like oh
here it is they're finally gonna like
give me something to do this you know i
thought that was pretty cool wow their
offer was so embarrassingly like
insulting
that it made me never go back again what
did they say free ice cream next time
you come or a discount they said um
if i if i do
um
it was like something like five posts um
like for a month or some [ __ ] it was
ridiculous it was like five posts a
video this long last thing i had to
write about it did you do a feature film
about writing
yeah
20 pictures
professional
it was all this [ __ ] and in exchange
they would give me a voucher for like
five free ice creams or something wow
and i was like so you're paying me in
like uh
it's basically coming back to you either
way like i'm buying this [ __ ] yeah yeah
so i was like i'm not getting anything
like i'm i'm still having to like all
the value the return goes right back to
them there's no i was so insulted i
can't eat ice cream anymore really
i want to just build myself because i
did it for years off the just like just
because you like to do it i just liked
writing i just liked it you should have
responded who's the idiot behind this
account dude
me and nikki had this [ __ ] kubrick
drink machine it was sick
you put a little pot in it makes you a
mojito and [ __ ] right it's unbelievable
so we're posting about it and then all
our people are like yo we want to
[ __ ] buy this thing where do we buy
it and then we reach out to them we're
like yo can you give us like a promo
code or something or like even if it
gives you people like like 10 bucks off
or something and then they reach back to
us and they're basically like
um yeah like you can use this promo code
it's just what everyone already has
and so it was like okay cool here you go
guys it's what everyone already has
and then um
and then people were just buying it
anyway because everyone wanted it
because it was so sick and then me and
nick nicki like wrote them a thing like
hey like you you guys like really need
to [ __ ] figure out your marketing
because like everyone's
doesn't know about this machine yet
nobody knows about it and when we're
trying to like help people spread
awareness about it you guys are
basically just like use the already code
but you guys should get better at this
uh we just don't think it's the word
getting out about your machine nobody's
talking about it so for us and then they
discontinued the machine like three
months later
it was just like the mosquito machine
because they were petty and they said oh
yeah
i'm turning it off you can't even buy
anything there are some dinosaurs at
these
these marketing places where they just
use these way old school methods that
don't work anymore and they think that
it'll still work they probably try to
put an ad on the penny saver and be like
we made it yeah we made it yeah it
wasn't it was interesting we were just
trying to tell them like yo you guys got
to get this [ __ ] out there we love your
product yeah you guys what are you doing
we want to keep it going because we like
the pods so much we know that if it ever
leaves shells we won't be able to use
our machine anymore and that's what
happens was there a response were keurig
shut up essentially that's that's the
thing that sucks about it it's like this
thing that we were buying it right it
was like a dollar 59 or something so
you're giving me five vouchers to now
not have to pay a dollar fifty nine
here's five dollars like to do probably
a lot of work that i would have to like
schedule myself to do them now rather
than just coincidentally well i mean
rite aid thrifty is like dude
that company feels like they're stuck in
1920 because even their logo and the ice
cream and that's why people like it why
even have someone in the marketing
position i guarantee you it's it's a
it's like a marketing intern that's like
yeah that's like that but it's like
that's that's in junior college right
now typing you that's some old lady dude
it's some old dude and he's like you
know what we could do
they would love this they love the ice
cream let's just give them ice cream
these guys will do everything for free
right that's what's crazy is like i i've
heard offers that you're just like oh no
thanks but this like
is enough to turn you off to wanting to
ever do it again when i get those offers
i'll be like nah it's easier for me to
just buy your product it is i just say
that to him under two bucks as it is i
already bought it can you just make it a
little bit different for people
it's weird that the common sense wasn't
there to realize that there's no
incentive to do the thing that they're
asking also they reached out right i
didn't i didn't hit them up right i
would just like hashtag them and then
they reached out so they have a person
in place right i'm gonna find all these
people to target them you know can you
use your audience to like chill out our
product and get nothing in return
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you